[Music]
you look fantastic I love your suit
Thanks the best-dressed guy here thank
you so much for coming on the show yeah
well no I I was thrilled to have you on
first of all congratulations on winning
the Critics Choice Award what an
achievement for anybody but at your age
you win this prestigious award where is
the award now I don't have it yet
because they have to engrave my name on
it
mm-hmm and then I'll get it and then
I'll put up beside my Millennium Falcon
[Applause]
what is it made of Legos morning Falcon
or is it a plaster is it which kind of
money Falcon that's and you get you have
it like on a someplace special and you
can put your award right next to it yeah
yeah I'm sorry it's so obvious you're a
big star Wars fan are you a fan of the
old ones or the brand-new one which is
all of them you just love those films
don't you okay you just did a movie with
the director who is going to do the next
Star Wars movie is that right yes Colin
Trevorrow yes you just did a film with
him did you ask him if you could have a
role in the next Star Wars movie you
know how many times I asked him
I said to him every day I could be a
baby Ewok I could be star across
flashback I could be Chewbacca you could
beat you Baca little chip yeah it's just
gotta be a baby Chewbacca right or the
Chewbacca when he's a little kid right
so of course he could be Chewbacca so
you were just pitching him all the time
yeah yeah you should say to him this
phrase I gotta make a living here just
say that to him that's that gets
grown-ups to listen to you which is
better do you think the movie room
that's everyone loves or star wars which
movie do you get more excited about
island jump jumping down say yeah yeah
yeah brooms a very intense movie its
rooms a great movie it's a great movie
but you can't compare it with Star Wars
I've never seen you this Angry before
people go crazy over Star Wars because
it's like it's the one of the best
trilogies in the world mm-hmm right yes
I agree with you I agree with you and
you you shouldn't only a fool would
compare them and I shouldn't have tried